life is all about holes you spend your
life trying to fit into one but that's
the last thing you should want because
when you die trust me you'll fit no
matter how round a peg you are
eventually you go nicely into a
rectangular hole it's your job to do
what john mccain did never willingly fit
never lie down and quit make a fuss make
everyone work harder in fact you can
measure a life by the size of the hole
needed to accommodate it make sure yours
is McCain sized there are people whose
exit leaves a Grand Canyon size space
that can never truly be filled
Senator McCain left that space and while
condolences may often feel trite they
can help fill that space especially when
there are millions of them Senator
McCain was foremost an independent
thinker a round peg in the world capital
of square holes he owned his thoughts
critics be damned his experiences taught
him to shrug off stuff that would have
left us in tears five and a half years
in a prison camp will do that to you and
that's real diversity he was feisty
funny and real we need a good John
McCain and not just every generation but
every day somebody who reminds us that
we don't all have to act the same and
who knows that there is a difference
between a good idea and the latest idea
the earth is covered in cemeteries
endless green acres of rectangular holes
there's one near you and in your future
but if there's an army of round pegs
filling square holes won't be easy in
life via John McCain be a little less
predictable tomorrow than you were today
realize that politics is only a small
part of life not life itself be the
round peg that refuses to fit in Dana I
heard you earlier talk about John McCain
when the news came out I just want to
get your thoughts on I don't know his
passing and well I didn't know him until
after 2001 I came to the bush White
House after 9/11 and any time that John
McCain was around it was a joyous time
his break actually he could be quite
cantankerous and you will find there
were many people in Washington who got
you know their heads ripped off by him
but they always respected him he was a
joy to have as an ally and could be a
really tough person if he wasn't on your
side right but you he commanded such
respect that you would have to listen to
him one of the big fights or I should
say was in fight but a disagreement was
about enhanced interrogation techniques
in the wake of the war on terror at 9/11
and he felt so strongly and you couldn't
disagree he had gone through it right he
knew what he was talking about and so I
remember those fights but the other
thing that I remember too is because I
wasn't there on the 2000 campaign I only
knew John McCain as a friend
yeah George W Bush and an ally and as I
learned more about about how difficult
and tough that primer and bitter that
primary was when George W Bush finally
wins in South Carolina over McCain that
what a remarkable level of forgiveness
happens between adversaries that then
they can go on to work and then as a
staffer that's really great because then
you can work with their staff and
there's no bitterness there's no
recriminations what I've really enjoyed
in the past two days is reading stories
that I didn't know yeah and a few of
them having to do with all the things
that I really loved about him especially
the freedom fighting his belief that
America was a force for good in the
world and that he would never ever
during recess would he go and take a
vacation he always went to see the
troops were to visit somebody who needed
America's help and obviously he will be
missed he's a man of principle he evokes
strong emotions and people definitely
nobody's neutral Brian I I don't know if
you had any personal dealings with him
beef you know nice table yes feel free
to make some up right that's true know
that they're all based on a true story
and here's the thing it's a little like
covering sports when you first break in
at 22 you have the worst mic flag there
is you're in the worst station at the
worst time and you walk into a locker
room and they treat you just like your
mic flag so you're not on a network with
John McCain he treated everyone equal he
made people seem important but not
patronizing he would come on to deliver
he had something to say every day and
I'm wondering it seemed like there's
only five people working in the Senate
and every major issue
you have an opinion there's a problem in
Syria there's an unrest so next thing
you know he is in Syria at 78 years old
meeting with the Free Syrian Army
there's a problem the Ukraine there's an
insurrection
well it's 510 degrees below zero he is
sitting there on a stage in the Ukraine
and they're saying John McCain will come
on with you in the morning because there
are 12 hours at a time saying this is
unbelievable the other thing I would
keep in mind with John McCain which I
thought was fantastic
he's sincerely admitted when he was
wrong the Keating five I blew it
he always regret I don't think this is
wrong but he regretted the confession
they beat out of him in the big picture
he also I also think that when it came
to the collapsing of the economy I think
that at one point he lost a Barack Obama
a Barack Obama calmly picked with the
phone and talked to Hank Paulson said
what's going on where John McCain
suspended his campaign and got angry
in retrospect he says you know I could
have handled that better it's kind of
cool to think that you could be that
important admit you have wrong and still
Ford straight ahead why you must have
interviewed him a number of times in
your career anything any experiences
that strike you well he could be really
angry you know that's not a joke John
McCain would be furious with me at times
and and what for what what what well
what I remember the one that really
stands out was in oh seven he was losing
in the Republican primaries and the
question was why is he carrying on and I
would ask that publicly on special
report I'd say yeah you know I don't see
why McCain bothers to stay in this race
and he just well he did not react well
and he specially didn't react well when
he came back and won yeah and he loved
the idea that he would stick it to me
that say hey we're supposed to be so
smart about paulista huh so I mean
that's the way he felt about it that's
fine but you know what strikes me is
that through it all anger or whatever
was the sense of honor and you know you
know people in the military and the
rarity of John McCain is that his
granddad and his dad were both Admirals
and then he goes to the US military US
Naval Academy in Annapolis which is
where he will be buried and he's not an
outstanding student but he is a
dedicated person and when he goes to war
he
a dedicated person I think he's the kind
of person based on the honor that he
displayed as a politician that I would
have want at my back if I'm under fire
and when you saw John McCain's statement
the statement that he issued knowing
that he was about to die he talked about
American ideals Greg in terms of this is
a country based on an idea not on blood
and soil and he spoke with a depth that
I don't hear from politicians about what
real patriotism is that you know
politicians are always glad to wrap
themselves in the flag and patriot not
john mccain and he could have done it
more easily than any of them because he
really was as the innocent in a prison
camp and tortured i'm not saying he was
just held tortured and displayed to me
what was the greatest example of honor
that I can think of as somebody I know
which is not to allow yourself to be
freed right because the enemy knows that
your dad is in charge of the troops
right and you're not going to let
yourself be freed as a propaganda
statement and leave your brothers behind
I don't think there's any higher tribute
that I could give to John McCain and to
recount that story today now that's it's
an amazing amazing story to me yeah and
I think a lot of people watching and a
lot of the people listen to my radio
show have serious disagreements
politically obviously with Senator
McCain and we've expressed those and
there's going to be time in the future
to have those critiques this is a time
though to reflect on somebody and all of
us really more than just what we see
necessarily on television more than in
one moment that reflects something and
who someone is and what they've
contributed it within the larger context
and his final statement I think says
something very appropriate for all of us
across the spectrum about not
surrendering right about what really
matters and that's the message
especially for Trump supporters that
they can learn from that no matter
what's going on that you continue on
with what matters to you that you can
none of us are going to get out of this
alive right we're going to hopefully
have a wonderful moment at the end where
we can think about what mattered if we
did what we could and every single way
and that is what I think all of us are
trying to do and he also mentioned of
course the thing that gave him the
strength and I worked on that campaign
briefly in a peripheral Way in 2000
the difference was his family his wife
and his his daughter Megan who I got to
know a little bit and that of course was
was just a foundation for him I think
that makes a huge difference for every
politician for all of us who do these
things and of course in the future
there's going to be much more critique
discussion about his legacy and the
nature of what he's been able to
accomplish the things he's done when it
comes to legislation and how we move
forward from this but I think ultimately
it's about sticking with your principles
not being bullied away from them
continuing on to help make this country
stronger and better and I think we're
we're in a good position doing that all
right